This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's this 80s movie that I have a real soft spot for. I saw it in the theater, in fact. Now I get to show it to my kids. It's a good one, which is a good thing because when your kids like a movie, you end up watching it over and over again. It's called The Never Ending Story. The Never Ending Story? What's that? The Never Ending Story is a tale of a boy adventure or named...
这里是99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。有一部80年代的电影，我真的非常喜欢。事实上，我当时是在电影院看的。现在我终于可以把它放给我的孩子们看了。这是一部好电影，这很棒，因为当你的孩子喜欢一部电影时，你最终会陪着他们看了一遍又一遍。它叫做《大荒芜的故事》。《大荒芜的故事》？那是什么？《大荒芜的故事》是一个关于一个男孩冒险的故事，或者说名叫……
A TRIO! He and his luck dragon named... A TRIO! ...are trying to save the world from the onslaught of a terrible force called... Look at Trio, the nothing! But this story also takes place inside of a book that's being read by a present day boy, a boy named. Pretty much all the dialogue in the movie is written with exclamation points.
一个三人组！他和他的幸运龙名叫……一个三人组！……正试图从一种可怕力量的猛烈袭击中拯救世界，这种力量被称为……看这个三人组，虚无！但这个故事也发生在一本正在被一个现代男孩阅读的书里面，一个名叫……的男孩。电影中几乎所有的对话都带有感叹号。
Anyway, so Bastion the Reader realizes that he is actually written into the story and it's up to him to save the storybook world. Bashin winds up defeating the nothing, since spoiler alert, by giving the Empress of the Fantasy World a new name. It's really hard to hear but he names her moon child there. I didn't know that for like 20 years. The power of one child's imagination saves an entire world. Seriously it's a great movie. Anyway, there is a reason why I'm telling you this story. I want you to hold on to that idea that a name can defeat...
总之，读者巴斯蒂安意识到他实际上已经被写进了故事里，拯救故事书世界的重任落在了他的肩上。巴斯蒂安最终击败了虚无，剧透警告，通过给奇幻世界的女皇起了一个新名字。这真的很难听到，但他把她命名为了“月亮孩子”。我大约有20年都不知道这一点。一个孩子想象力的力量拯救了整个世界。说真的，这是一部很棒的电影。总之，我给你讲这个故事是有原因的。我希望你记住这样一个想法：一个名字可以打败……
...unnothing. Okay, with that in mind, here's our producer, Sam Greensman. Hey, Roman. Alright, everyone, in a listener land. Names versus... nothing. When I was a kid growing up in South Florida, there was this beautiful green place where I always wanted to go play. It looked perfect for a kid to run around and throw a ball.
……虚无。好了，带着这个想法，有请我们的制作人山姆·格林斯潘。嗨，罗曼。好了，各位听众朋友们。名字对阵……虚无。当我还是个在南佛罗里达长大的孩子时，有一个美丽绿色地方，我总是想去那里玩。它看起来非常适合一个小孩子到处奔跑和扔球。
It was a flat mode lawn that just stretched into infinity, but my parents wouldn't ever take me there. But with good reason. It was inside of a giant highway interchange. My 5 year old self would never have been able to convince my parents that this would be a good place to play, because no responsible parent takes their kid to play catch off the side of i95. But I don't think I would even have known how to ask them to place to play, because no responsible parent takes their kid to play catch off the side of i95. But I don't think I would even have known how to ask them to take me there, because this
那是一片平坦的无草坪，一直延伸到无限远处，但我的父母从来不带我去那里。不过这是有原因的。它位于一个巨大的高速公路立交桥里面。我5岁的自己永远无法说服父母这是一个适合玩耍的好地方，因为没有哪个负责任的父母会带孩子去95号州际公路旁玩接球游戏。但我认为我甚至不知道该如何要求他们带我去那里，因为这个
place isn't really anywhere that we think of as being a place. There's no name for it. Let's call it a nothing. As a kid, I couldn't look away from these perfect grassy areas, but as I grew up and became a driver, I learned to ignore them like everyone else. So what happens when you give that nothing to name? That's totally what I'm doing. Giving things a name. So this is my friend Graham. My name is Graham Carell Allen.
地方实际上并不是我们认为的“地方”。它没有名字。我们姑且称之为“虚无”吧。小时候，我无法将视线从这些完美的长满青草的区域移开，但当我长大并成为一名司机时，我和其他人一样学会了忽视它们。所以，当你给这个“虚无”赋予一个名字时会发生什么？我完全就是在做这件事。给事物起名字。所以这是我的朋友格雷厄姆。我的名字叫格雷厄姆·卡雷尔·艾伦。
Graham's an artist in Baltimore and he has this project where he's trying to categorize and classify all the different kinds of invisible public spaces that we overlook. He published a field guide for how to spot them. It's part of a bigger project called New Public Sites. New public sites is an investigation into some of the invisible sites and overlooked features of our everyday public spaces within cities that are not traditionally framed as public space.
格雷厄姆是巴的尔的摩的一位艺术家，他有一个项目，试图对我们忽视的各种隐形公共空间进行分类和归纳。他出版了一本关于如何发现它们的实地指南。这是一个名为“新公共场所”的更大项目的一部分。新公共场所是对城市中日常公共空间的一些隐形场所和被忽视特征的调查，这些特征传统上不被视为公共空间。
It's important to name these places because by giving these places succinct and fun and poetic names, we can help start a discourse about our public spaces and how we wanna envision them for the future. I'm reminded of the never ending stories. Bastion, you must give me a name. Call my name!
给这些地方命名是很重要的，因为通过赋予这些地方简洁、有趣和富有诗意的名字，我们可以帮助引发一场关于我们的公共空间以及我们希望如何为未来构想它们的讨论。这让我想起了《大荒芜的故事》。巴斯蒂安，你必须给我一个名字。呼唤我的名字！
See? Graham gives these tours where he puts this language to use, describing incredibly boring pieces of the Baltimore landscape. This is the first site along the tour, and here we have a void. I remember the building that used to stand here, it was painted blue. Passing through it you can imagine how us as ghosts should the building be standing here would have to actually be invisible to pass through these walls and now it's the reverse. The building is the ghost and
看？格雷厄姆带领的旅行中运用了这些语言，描述了巴尔的摩景观中极其无聊的部分。这是旅程中的第一个站点，这里我们有一个虚无。我记得以前立在这里的那栋建筑，它被刷成了蓝色。穿过它，你可以想象如果我们作为幽灵，如果这栋建筑还立在这里，将不得不真正隐形才能穿过这些墙壁，而现在情况正好相反。建筑变成了幽灵，而
we're we're passing through its walls. So Graham is really giving a tour of a vacant lot. Vagan lot is one way to put it, but notice what Graham called it. A void. And if you pull up his book that Graham published sort of a field guide to these new public sites, you'll see... I hang on. Okay, I don't have the book handy, but here this is a PDF. I want to do command F, the OID,D, page 14, void.
我们正在穿过它的墙壁。所以格雷厄姆实际上是在带大家参观一片空地。空地是另一种说法，但请注意格雷厄姆是怎么称呼它的。一个虚无。如果你翻开格雷厄姆出版的那本书，可以说是这些新公共场所的实地指南，你会看到……等等。好吧，我手头没有这本书，但这里有一个PDF。我想用Ctrl+F搜索，V-O-I-D，第14页，虚无。
A framed open space imputed with the psychic presence of a former mass. Andor the profound immersion of seductively infinite nothingness. That certainly is a something. To find out more about these invisible public spaces, Graham and Sam load bikes to the edge of East Baltimore to look at a few, like the one Sam pint for as a kid. It looks like there's a small parting that we can actually see through. Right now we're at the foot of a small embankment that's probably 15 feet tall or so.
一个被前一个巨大质量的精神存在所注入的带框开放空间。以及/或者被诱人的无限虚无深深吞没。这确实算得上是一个“东西”。为了解更多关于这些隐形公共空间的信息，格雷厄姆和山姆骑着自行车来到巴尔的摩东部的边缘去看几个，就像山姆小时候渴望的那个。看起来有一个我们可以真正看穿的小裂缝。现在我们处于一个小路堤的脚下，大概有15英尺左右高。
We're going to walk up to the edge of this embankment and meet a low-lying concrete wall that will safely separate us from the clover leaf of traffic. Right beyond this on ramp on to we'll be able to hopefully actually look into a freeway eddy. So let's do that right now. Right now we're starting across the street during a huge lulling traffic. So we're looking at this curved highway exit ramp coming in front of us and it's maybe
我们将走到这个路堤的边缘，遇到一面低矮的混凝土墙，它将把我们与交通环岛安全地隔离开。越过这个上匝道，我们希望能够真正看到一个高速公路漩涡。所以我们现在就这么做。现在我们趁着交通巨大的间歇开始过街。所以我们正在看着这个在我们前方逼近的弯曲的高速公路出口匝道，它大概
about 15 feet, 20 feet ahead of us. There's kind of this almost like a wilderness area. Fence Stins is no trespassing by the Maryland Transportation Authority. With the invisible public space and site, Graham turns to his field manual. Freeway Eddie, an interstitial fragment of space between intersecting curves of highway pavement. And there you have it.
在我们前方约15英尺、20英尺的地方。这里几乎就像是一个荒野区。围栏上写着马里兰州交通管理局的“严禁入内”。通过这个隐形的公共空间和地点，格雷厄姆翻开了他的实地手册。高速公路漩涡，高速公路路面交错曲线之间的一块间质碎片空间。这就是了。
That grassy, non-place I'd always wanted to hang out in as a kid. Now is the name of Freeway Eddie. Graham's field guide to new public sites to hang out in as a kid, now as a name, a freeway eddie. Grampsfield God to new public sites is full of new identities for these kind of places. So here we have median refuge, a liminal zone of linear respite between parallels of churning traffic. In lightened elevation, supple terrain,
那个我小时候总是想去闲逛的长满青草的“非地方”。现在它有了名字叫“高速公路漩涡”。格雷厄姆的新公共场所实地指南里充满了这类地方的新身份。所以这里我们有中央隔离带避难所，车流平行线之间线性休憩的临界地带。发光的挑高，柔软的地形，
providing the ideal incline from which one may gaze from a wise viewing distance. Monumental isolation. Big loose parts, movable materials that invite playful reconfiguration. It is actually an architectural term. Big loose parts. It's a pretty fun sounding term if you ask me. Paralax of chance. Triangle crossing. A three-sided concrete platform or asphalt zone, providing solace for street crossing pedestrians. I don't see too many pedestrians. We have oral saturation. The overwhelming occupation of a surrounding soundscape by sight generated occupation of a surrounding soundscape by sight generated, droning noise. A median refuge, a liminal pause of restraint.
提供了人们可以从明智的观看距离进行凝视的理想倾斜度。不朽的孤立。大型松散部件，邀请人们进行趣味性重组的可移动材料。这实际上是一个建筑术语。大型松散部件。如果你问我，这是一个听起来挺有趣的术语。机缘巧合的视差。三角形交叉口。一个三面混凝土平台或沥青区域，为过马路的行人提供慰藉。我没看到太多行人。我们有听觉饱和。周围音景被视线生成的占用完全压倒，周围音景被视线生成的、轰鸣的噪音所占用。中央隔离带避难所，一种克制的临界暂停。
Empty signifier, a post or a pole absent of its original sign and or meaning. If there's a common theme connecting these sites, it's that they're mostly the empty leftover spaces from Car Centered City Planning. And it's an odd celebration of these nothing places. Listen to how Graham describes them. Beauty, beauty, beauty that one can enjoy, spectacular and sublime, quite beautiful.
空能指，一个失去了原初符号和/或意义的柱子或杆子。如果说这些地点之间有一个共同的主题，那就是它们大多是以汽车为中心的城市规划中空置的残留空间。这是对这些虚无之地的一种奇怪的庆典。听听格雷厄姆是如何描述它们的。美，美，人们可以欣赏的美，壮丽而崇高，相当美丽。
This is a really beautiful spot. We're actually standing right now in a long strip of sunlight that is created by the space between these two elevated highways. We're at the Chinatown bus stop across the street from the Baltimore travel plaza. Miles outside of the city, perhaps the most unglamorous way to enter Baltimore and yet it's a gateway for hundreds a week and it's a quite beautiful space. What were... Here's where I got to drive the line, Grant, because there's some trees, there's some birds,
这是一个非常美丽的景点。我们现在实际上正站在一条长长的阳光带中，这是由这两座高架高速公路之间的空间创造的。我们位于巴尔的摩旅游广场街对面的唐人街巴士站。距离城市数英里远，也许是进入巴尔的摩最不迷人的方式，然而它却是每周数百人的门户，而且这是一个相当美丽的太空。我们是什么……这就是我必须划清界限的地方，格雷厄姆，因为这里有一些树，有一些鸟，
you know, there's, I guess, some intent of landscaping this area around here. But I mean, it's basically a big parking lot with some trucks, with diesel gas across the street. There's a subway, there's a bus stop. What are your grounds for calling this beautiful? Let's be clear here. You can call that grassy patch off the highway, a freeway eddy, all you want. But I'm not going to take my kids to play ball in one. A highway exit ramp by any of their name is still justice unattractive and dangerous.
你知道，这里周围的景观设计大概有一些意图。但我的意思是，这基本上是一个大型停车场，街对面有卡车、柴油气。这里有地铁，有公交车站。你称之为美丽的理由是什么？我们要搞清楚这一点。你可以把高速公路旁的那片草地随心所欲地叫做“高速公路漩涡”。但我不会带我的孩子们去那里打球。无论高速公路出口匝道叫什么名字，它依然同样没有吸引力且危险。
This is beautiful because it's a space that's shared by so many and yet it was completely undesigned. This space was designed as a parking lot and it's become this huge nexus for people coming in and out of Baltimore. And so it's not necessarily what it looks like, it's more about what it represents. Yeah, there's no denying the experience of being in these new public sites is actually pretty terrible. But for Graham, the beauty is in their potential. Sometimes every day unremarkable spaces can become something more simply by virtue of people being there. It's worth noting here that Zucati Park in New York City,
这是美丽的，因为它是一个被这么多人共享的空间，然而它完全是没有经过设计的。这个空间被设计成了一个停车场，它已经成为了人们进出巴尔的摩的一个巨大枢纽。所以它不一定在于它看起来是什么样子的，更在于它代表了什么。是的，不可否认，身处这些新公共场所的体验其实相当糟糕。但对格雷厄姆来说，美在于它们的潜力。有时，日常不起眼的暗淡空间可以通过人们身处其中这一事实而变得更加宏大。这里值得一提的是，纽约市的祖科蒂公园，
the birthplace of the Occupy movement, was a privately owned space and not a public park. So if your goal is finding new spaces for engaged democracy to happen as it is for Graham, then you need a way to redefine the places in your neighborhood where that kind of activity can happen. And I think it's important not not to fetishize public spaces as only existing in town squares or you'll simmity your Yellowstone or something like this, not just the National Mall and DC, for example, but any place are everyday public spaces, you know, the spaces that we all share, it's everywhere and we all have access to it. These spaces are the places where this happens.
占领运动的发源地，是一个私人所有的空间，而不是公共公园。因此，如果你的目标是为参与式民主的发生寻找新的空间，就像格雷厄姆的那样，那么你需要有一种方法来重新定义你邻里中可以发生这种活动的地方。我认为重要的是不要把公共空间神圣化为仅存在于城市广场中，否则你只会向往你的黄石公园或类似的地方，不仅仅是华盛顿特区的国家广场，例如，任何地方都是我们的日常公共空间，你知道的，我们所有人共享的空间，它无处不在，我们所有人都可以使用它。这些空间就是这一切发生的地方。
It doesn't just happen over the internet. It happens in physical spaces. New public sites are these physical spaces that we can appropriate, that we can make our own. If it's only for a temporary demonstration, then so be it, but maybe it's for a farmer's market, maybe it's for a community garden, maybe it's simply for a playground
它不仅仅通过互联网发生。它发生在物理空间中。新的公共场所就是我们可以占有的、我们可以使其成为我们自己的这些物理空间。如果这只是一场暂时的示威，那就随它去吧，但也许它是为了农夫市集，也许它是为了社区花园，也许它只是为了一个游乐场
or a place where we need to add a few benches to make it a better bus stop. But nevertheless, there's potential there and by giving it a name and by starting that conversation, we can kind of get these ideas moving into reality. So it all comes back to a name against a nothing. When you give a nothing a name, you can reimagine it as a something. If we can create terms for these otherwise invisible experiences and places and things, that we all share, that we all of us share in these public spaces, these new public sites,
或者一个我们需要添加几张长椅以使其成为更好的公交车站的地方。但尽管如此，潜力就在那里，通过给它一个名字并开启那场对话，我们可以把这些想法转化为现实。所以这一切都归结为一个名字对阵一个虚无。当你给一个虚无赋予一个名字时，你可以把它重新想象成某种东西。如果我们能为这些我们所有人共享的、我们所有人在这些公共空间（这些新的公共场所）中共享的、原本看不见的体验、地方和事物创造出术语，
then it's a starting point. It's a starting point for that conversation. By giving it a term, we can then talk about it, and we all know what we're talking about. Then that's the first step. The second step is envisioning, okay, well, how does this need to be improved? And the third step is how do we do that? The naming is where it starts.
那么这就是一个起点。那是那场对话的起点。通过给它一个术语，我们就可以谈论它，并且我们都知道我们在谈论什么。然后这是第一步。第二步是构想，好吧，这需要如何改进？第三步是我们如何做到这一点。命名就是一切开始的地方。
I don't know if I name anything in the moon child though. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Sam Greenspan with help from me Roman Mars. It's a project of KALW-91.7 local public radio in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, I tweet at Roman Mars to find out more about Graham's project and his mobile app, which will help you identify and even make up new names for your new public sites and your own backyard. Check out our website at snoninepersoninvisible.org.
不过我不知道我是不是给月亮孩子里的什么东西起过名字。本周的《99% Invisible》由山姆·格林斯潘制作，罗曼·马尔斯协助。这是旧金山本地公共广播电台KALW-91.7与旧金山美国建筑师协会合作的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞该节目，我会在推特@Roman Mars上发帖，以了解更多关于格雷厄姆的项目以及他的移动应用程序的信息，这将帮助你识别甚至为你的后院的新公共场所编造新名字。请查看我们的网站snoninepersoninvisible.org。
You too, beware. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你也要小心。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。